I can tell you the day that my financial
life changed it came in two parts
I was driving I've been working really
hard as a young man working on this
business that I was in at the time and I
I was working 18-hour days and I was
totally broke I mean like trying to make
sure I don't have gas to get from one
location to the next
and I just finished like 11:30 at night
I was driving down the 57 freeway in a
place called Pomona California not a
great part of town at that stage almost
midnight and I was emotional I just kept
thinking to myself why is it I'm working
so hard and I'm still not succeeding and
I was mad about it and I had this
tipping point inside I don't know what
triggered it but I got really emotional
I literally pulled off the side of the
freeway and I hope always had these
written journals I spelled the journal
to this day and I wrote in giant letters
the secret to living is giving and then
I started crying and it was one of those
beautiful moments and it's just like I
realized I was so focused on what I was
getting I was not focused on what I was
giving enough and so for about six
months that really emboldened me and I
and I did really well and then I had
some frustrations some failures and and
then I got mad because of people I
counted on it not followed through and
and I found myself totally broke again I
mean like nothing not down to
twenty-something dollars not knowing how
I'm gonna feed myself and I reached out
a friend I loaned $1000 to and he kept
avoiding my calls I was madder and
madder like I helped him and he was in
need he won't even give me my money back
and in the midst of all this anger I had
to figure out what to do so I've always
been a pragmatist so when I was just 17
I was on my own I used to save the money
go to the Smorgasburg on my bike load up
for the winter eat everything I could so
it lasts me a day or two and you'll pay
the least amount of money for the most
food so I thought there's a smorgasbord
but it's I lived in Venice California
and there's a place called Marina del
Rey just three miles away and it's very
wealthy environment and on the water
there's a place there called El Torito
it's a restaurant it's still there and
it's very nice it's on the water boats
going by and they had an all-you-can-eat
salad bar taco taco bar so I said I'm
going to go there so I didn't spend the
money on my car for the gas for the
three miles I walked there I'm not gonna
pay for parking I was monitoring every
dime total scarcity and I got there and
I loaded up made everything I could
possibly eat and while I was sitting
there eating
door opening a very attractive woman
came in and I was waiting to see who her
boyfriend husband was gonna be and there
wasn't a boyfriend her husband there was
a kid about this tall and he was dressed
in a suit a little vest and he came all
the door open for his mom he'll pulled
out the chair and set her down he was
just such a gentleman and then he stared
in his mom's eyes and he was just he was
just so I don't know I was just so
loving so they're so present and it
moved me even my selfish little stupid
place I just moved by the love Yonkers
mom respect the Emperor's mom I don't
know what it was but I went paid the
bill and you know I don't had 17 18 19
dollars left whatever wise I put put in
my pocket you know hang on to what
little money I'd left I think was like
595 for all you can eat in those days or
something like that and and I walked up
this little boy and I said hi and I
shook his hand so what's your name and I
don't really member his name he was
Ronnie he said I'm Ronnie I think it was
and Serve Ronnie I said you are such a
gentleman I said I saw you open the door
for your lady I saw you pulled out the
chair I said you were a class act
and he looked at me goes she's my mom
and I said well that's even better he
said I said well it's so cool you're
taking her to lunch like this and he
goes oh I can't believe taking her lunch
I don't have a job yet I'm just 11 right
and I said I said well I said he's 11
and I said to him I said well yes you
are you are taking a lunch he said what
do you mean I just reached in my pocket
I had no plan there was no strategy I
just grabbed my money in my pocket I put
it right down the table and found him
changing all about bills and all and he
looked up his eyes got really big I said
you are taking her to lunch and he said
I can't take that I said sure you can he
said why I said because I'm bigger than
you are
Hey and he eyes got this big and he
smiled really big and I mean look at the
lady I just shook his hand I walked out
and I didn't walk out I flew out I had
no car it's like I was like muscle look
like an idiot I'm sure I was skipping it
to some extent I was just like purely
euphoric at the moment when I should
have been the most freaked out I mean I
just gave away my last dollar in or my
next dollar I don't have any money on
other words my next meal gonna come from
zero fear was like I went home that
night I laid up this plan how I was
gonna turn things around but you know I
wasn't gonna turn around in a day
- my turn on a week or two and I thought
well people fast all the time I'll go on
a fast
I was positive about it like and I woke
up the next day and I got my little
normal snail mail on those days and sure
enough there's this handwritten note I
open it up and there's your check inside
it's from the man that me $1,000 does
not return my phone calls
$4,000 plus some additional money saying
I'm really sorry and you were there for
me and I feel bad about it here it is
what was beautiful about the moment was
and I cried honestly and I and I said I
looked at this thing and I thought to
myself you know what does this mean you
know why did this happen and I don't
know if it's true but I chose to mean
that money came because I did the right
thing because I didn't operate from
scarcity because I didn't a little soul
was in front of me my heart knew what
was right and I didn't hesitate I just
did what was right and I can remember to
this day so vividly like it was
yesterday because that's the day I
became a wealthy man that's the day that
scarcity ended in me and that didn't
mean I'm in more ups and downs
financially had plenty of those but I
never everyone back to that place of
being angry at somebody else who had
more or blaming other people what do
they got what they did fairly or
unfairly who the hell am I to say what I
want to do is focus instead on being a
blessing in people's lives that if I
could find a way every day to do
something to add more value for other
people then I wouldn't have to worry
about anything just like you don't worry
about taking a breath of whether oxygens
going to be there you don't ask the
question you know it's going to be there
I figured if I left my life that way
where I spontaneously did was right
consistently I wouldn't have to worry
and I haven't another day sense that
doesn't mean enough stressful times but
I haven't gone back to that place of
scarcity and I really think that's what
this book is ultimately about gives you
all the tools all the strategies the
richest people on earth but it's also
about making that psychological
emotional if you want to call it
spiritual shift that really changes the
quality of life through effort which
makes you wealthy the day you stop being
scarce and the way that you give up your
heart your body your soul your mind and
your
you